what is the last digit of the following  number we have the fifth power of 11 to  the eight multiplied by 19 multiplied by  23 squared the answer choices are one  three five seven and nine  at first it seems like an impossible  problem to solve  but the key is that the last digit of a  product a times B times C is the product  of the last digits of a b and c  so we just need to focus on the last  digits which will be 1 9 and 3.  now furthermore 1 to the power of 8 will  be equal to one nine is just nine and  three squared is nine then we have one  times nine times nine which is equal to  81. once again we can focus on just the  last digit of one then one raised to the  fifth power is going to be one so the  correct answer is a one